today's episode is sponsored by blinkist
the app that lets you
read or listen to an entire nonfiction
book
in just 15 minutes you can try blinkist
totally free
and get 25 off a subscription when you
go to blinkist.com
davidpakman i put the link right below
this video
so over the last couple of days we've
spent some time
going through the really shocking
revelations that are made in bob
woodward's new book
rage including of course that donald
trump all the way back in february knew
the seriousness of coronavirus
downplayed it publicly
for political reasons even though he
clearly knew and now 200 000 people
nearly have died and that is shocking it
it's not an exaggeration to say that is
a shock it is shocking that anybody
would do that any human would do that
regardless of
their motivations or their position but
our friend and he is our friend he's
been on the show a couple of times steve
almond
wrote a really good commentary for wbur
which we are linking to uh you can also
check out
my interviews with steve allmand he
wrote a really good op-ed
where he makes the case that as
ridiculous as as donald trump's actions
are
as shocking and outrageous and immoral
as it is that donald trump
didn't just deceive about coronavirus i
mean he straight up lied knowingly lied
he didn't just get it wrong he lied the
real thing we should be horrified about
is that it won't matter and
i actually agree with steve allman i've
given this a lot of thought over the
last 24 hours
and yes donald trump publicly
said the virus is under control we shut
it down it's going to go away like a
miracle 15 cases will soon be zero
all of it privately he knew how serious
it was
he believed that it was so contagious in
early february that it was spreading
through the air and he said it to bob
woodward and it's insane
but as steve allman points out
the shock is that trump's support will
likely
not move as a result this story will
rage
for some period of time just like early
last week early this week late last week
rather
the troops are losers and suckers story
was raging
just like the ukraine story did just
like every story and then something else
will happen
and things will move on and donald
trump's approval will keep bouncing
between 39 and 47 and ultimately this
election is going to come down to
not the country realizes wow
this is bad hey we're a laughingstock
hey this is a joke we have to stop this
this election in the end is going to
come down to
can our turnout outdo
their voter suppression that is
ultimately what this will be about and
if you want
any proof of this simply spend some time
checking out the posts over the last 48
hours
in the typical pro-trump on enclaves of
the internet
and what you will find is that over the
last 48 hours as the story exploded
first of all for the most part the trump
has just ignored it they pretend the
story doesn't exist
and then when it does come up they
either say
it's fake news or they assail someone's
character
like bob woodward in this case they will
protect
trump at all costs the less involved
ones
will simply experience cognitive
dissonance and say can't possibly be
real
and almost every day it seems certainly
every week
there is a bombshell that would end
other presidencies it would they would
have ended other presidencies and i said
this yesterday and i think it bears
repeating
if the world really made sense trump
never would have been elected wouldn't
be possible the public wouldn't be so
stupid as to do it
but it happened if the world made a
little more sense than it does
trump would have had to resign by now
but instead trump has a shot at
four more years he really does and the
republican party
including mitch mcconnell and friends
mcconnell and friends mitch and friends
allowed this to happen they could have
intervened they could have removed trump
they could have voted to convict on
impeachment
they could have done any number of
things but they are also complicit and
they need to be punished as well
and hopefully some of them will be
punished by losing
martha mcsally for one and others but
later their punishment should come as
well i keep thinking back
to that speaker that woman at the dnc
who spoke
about her father who died of coronavirus
who
believed trump that um it wasn't really
serious
and she said you know it's kind of a
cliche line but but it is powerful in a
sense as well
she said her father's only pre-existing
condition
before he died before he caught
coronavirus was that he trusted
donald trump and meanwhile donald trump
has run counter propaganda we talked
yesterday how now donald trump has been
nominated by some far-right norwegian
politician
for a nobel peace prize if you can
imagine something more outrageous
and he's been retweeting that and
running a counter narrative
for a second step back come with me on
this thought experiment step back
imagine the worst thing trump could
possibly do okay what
and and what could it be and then how
would his base react and you will
realize that
this bob woodward fiasco is unlikely to
have a huge impact imagine an
audio tape of trump trump screaming the
n-word
imagine a video of him with putin
talking about a quid pro quo to win the
election imagine a video of trump
committing sexual assault or trump's
taxes come out and it turns out yeah
he's cheating on his taxes
i still don't think it would matter to a
large portion of his base
maybe maybe if trump was on video saying
the people who voted me they're suckers
and idiots
i wouldn't be caught dead with them i
don't even like them at my clubs
maybe that would make an impact and i'm
not even sure i think even in
that case if trump just straight up
insulted his followers
which he's done indirectly but if he did
it more directly
i think most of them still say you know
i don't need trump to like me
i just need him to make america great
and by the way i'm sure
he was talking about somebody else not
me specifically uh
he wasn't talking about followers like
me he was talking about supporters like
some other people
even in that case i struggled to see
how it really affects donald trump's
approval so
check out steve allman's piece on wbur
we're linking to it
uh about this i think steve is right i
think the real tragedy
is that this isn't going to hurt trump
in any kind of substantive way
donald trump we have now learned thanks
to
bob woodward's book rage supposedly
bragged about a secret nuclear weapon
system
when he was speaking to bob woodward
during these interviews that took place
over the last six months for bob
woodward's book this is according to
excerpts
from the book that have been released uh
trump talked openly
about a weapon system with bob woodward
that is
supposed to be secret and this was in
the context of telling bob woodward how
close we supposedly were to war with
north korea nuclear war in 2017
which is a whole horrifying nightmare in
and of itself and according to the
excerpts that the washington post has
published trump told bob woodward quote
i have built a nuclear a weapon system
that nobody's ever had in this country
before
we have stuff that you haven't even seen
or heard about
we have stuff that putin and she have
never heard about before
uh saying there's nobody what we have
is incredible and then in the book bob
woodward goes on
to say unnamed sources that he spoke to
and said what
what is trump talking about here sources
did
confirm the existence of a new weapon
system to bob woodward
but they said they couldn't share any
details and they expressed surprise
that donald trump actually mentioned it
to bob woodruff because he wasn't
supposed to
the hill then reached out to the
pentagon for comment
the pentagon said they don't talk about
books that have not yet been published
and um when the hill did more
investigation into this
they spoke to for example james acton
from the carnegie endowment for
international peace and uh
what james acton said is this probably
is a submarine-launched low-yield
nuclear warhead and its existence is
now known but the details remain
classified
this is so so there's two sides to this
one is we shouldn't even have this stuff
we need
nuclear disarmament and maybe
trump spilling the beans will help build
that case
the other side is donald trump is just
so irresponsible with classified and
secret information
and he criticized hillary clinton for
that and he criticizes adam schiff and
uh
chuck schumer and nancy pelosi for that
and yet it's trump who has the record
of bragging about new weapons that are
publicly uh
unknown or semi-known and disclosing
details remember the thing about the
supersonic missile that
super duper missile that goes 17 times
the speed of sound or whatever
remember donald trump in the oval office
spilling
secrets from an ally to russian
spy recruiter sergey kislyak on and on
and on
but on the tail end of this it's not
new that donald trump is irresponsible
with information and much of it is
because of his narcissism which i will
get to
consider that donald trump's kids have
access to a lot of this information
who has jared kushner told about this
stuff
what has ivanka done or don jr with
knowledge
of these things and this is the classic
attention seeking behavior of a
narcissist i've known many
serial liars in my life they're very
toxic very very toxic
sometimes they straight up for attention
say things that are lies
i knew someone i remember who said my
glasses are 500
no they're not and if they were i
wouldn't even care just they want
attention and they say
straight up lies others will say things
that are true but that they really
shouldn't be talking about
uh sometimes narcissists will in order
to
get attention they will um reveal a
secret
that a third party told them that they
really shouldn't be revealing as an
example and that is that that is part of
what donald trump does and he does his
fair share of lying as well
imagine the things he's told people
that we don't know he's told people and
imagine what our adversaries are quietly
doing with that knowledge this man is a
danger
he is a danger and he may get four more
years if we don't do the right thing
let me know what you think i'm on
twitter at d pacman glad you're with us
today remember next week we're on
vacation the show is okay we're not
cancelled
we're just going to going on vacation
next week but we've still got a full
show today
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly what one of
my favorite apps lets you do it's called
blinkist and what they do is take
thousands of popular non-fiction books
they condense them down into text or
audio that you can consume in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the
important core insights from each book
so it's perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for
if there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blinkist to get
a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
non-fiction book
in just 15 minutes i recently read a
brief history of time of course by the
great
stephen hawking this is a book that i
have been aware of for so long and
other things got in the way and it was
fantastic
to check it out on blinkist blinkist has
books on politics philosophy science
they have 27 different non-fiction
categories and a subscription
is only about eight bucks a month and
you get the entire
library but you can try it totally free
and get 25 off a subscription when you
go to blinkist.com
david pakman i've put the link right
underneath this video
[Music]
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
remember that the best way to support
the david pakman show
podcast youtube channel radio show
tv show satellite tv show twitch
channel live streams and everything else
is to become a member at joinpakman.com
it's quick
it's easy it feels good you can get the
bonus show every single day
and you can use the coupon code 2020 now
to save
66 off of the cost of a membership
consider it i'm inviting you go to
joinpakman.com
we are going to go to the phone lines at
617-830-4750 and see what is on the
minds of our viewers and listeners
starting today with our caller from the
623 area code who's calling today
from 623
uh hello yeah that's you
hi uh this is ricky from phoenix ricky
what's going on
hi um so i have two questions to ask you
first would be about
q anon and um i'm getting people to
actually deconvert from the conspiracy
theory
by your interviews really like which i i
mean i did one interview about it but
it's not a topic i've talked about too
much but that's helping people
yeah yeah so um a lot of people on
on my facebook have been posting about
you know like q a and stuff and all that
so
and you know they've been blaming joe
biden for some whatever reason saying
that he's a beautiful or whatever so
i have been you well i showed a video uh
to people about your
about your interview and then it's kind
of like
deconverting him from believing into
that kind of stuff that's good you know
what i'm saying
yeah that's great news if that's the
case i like them
yeah yeah it's because um a lot of
people don't want to vote for joe biden
because of the conspiracy theory so i'll
say
who knows if that's real or not but
let's face it this
did come from a white a right-wing group
so who knows if it's true or not
and you know i don't want you know since
we're in an election where like
it could go bad or it can go good who
knows um
yeah i'm just trying to like you know
deconvert people from thinking that so
we can actually get people to vote for
biden so we can at least like you know
hold the ball and you know go more left
from there you know what i'm saying
i i completely know what you're saying
and i think you're doing exactly the
right thing now at arizona interestingly
it's not looking so good for donald
trump right now
yeah um yeah also um i have been getting
people trying to vote for mark kelly as
well trying to get it blue so we can you
know
get martha mcsally out so hopefully it
does go blue for us in the senate
it would be amazing i think you know my
sense is if arizona does go blue
i think it's not going to be a good
night for donald trump nationally i
think it's not just going to be arizona
if it goes bad for trump
yeah yeah i i yeah i hope i hope you
know trump gets out of office but
i'm using your videos to actually you
know get people to vote for biden you
know like
if i see your videos on facebook i'll
share it if
i see anything that could actually
benefit people to like know more about
buying like
why it would be beneficial for people
i'll share your video maybe that's why
you're getting
you know 1 million subscribers you know
what i'm saying ricky i think you are
responsible for us getting to a million
subscribers absolutely i think you are
uh
you are overwhelmingly the source of
that and i really appreciate it
oh yeah so yeah i'm just trying to make
sure you know people make a better
choice in terms of this election because
i don't want to like make well you you
know well you get what i'm saying you
know
i got hopefully hopefully yeah but the
second question is
how can what are other ways i can get
people to vote for biden because
i get there's people too far gone but
there are people that are reluctant to
either vote or not vote
oh right yeah so so listen don't try to
argue with
i think arguing with trump supporters is
a much tougher thing to do than just
finding people who don't like trump but
who maybe
may not be planning to vote and explain
to them
donald trump is going to claim that it
was rigged we need every vote
it's not enough for joe biden to win by
a hundred votes he needs to win by a
million or ideally five million or
ideally seven million or whatever so
so if there's ever an election that
we need every vote for it's this one
because those extra votes are what could
be the difference between
trump credibly saying it was rigged and
trump not being believed when he says it
yeah no yeah i totally get you um yeah
um because i also bring about policy
like you know
uh biden wants to raise the minimum wage
to 15
that does catch a lot of people's eyes
in terms of
voting for biting so you know i do i do
use that tactic of just like you know
raising the minimum wage and just
at least better health care not it's not
the best but you know better than
nothing you know
i got you my friend all right ricky
great to hear from you you're doing
great work down there in arizona keep it
up okay
all right all right well thank you thank
you all right there's ricky from phoenix
doing
doing it all doing it all let's go next
to our caller from the 559
area code who's calling today from five
nine
hey david uh this is nick from l.a nick
from l.a what's going on i hear it's hot
there very hot
oh yeah it's been pretty hard um around
the 118
121 i think it was in woodland hills wow
yeah um a fan of your show i actually uh
know you from uh um it was like
a long time ago like probably about
eight years ago when you had an
interview with
um with uh anonymous okay and then
what's a
bro baptist search yes um i have two
i have two quick questions you don't
mind um
one i wanted to know if um
i wanted to know if if it was possible
for
let's say donald trump to go um
left on some policies do you think he
would actually do that in order to
try to win re-election i don't know that
there's anything trump can i mean we've
got seven weeks
and more and more people are going to be
voting early in absentee so a lot of
people
in four weeks a lot of people will have
voted i don't know that there's time now
for donald trump to get any policy done
i mean he can he can throw some
executive orders together if he thinks
it will help him
but uh i think it's too late for policy
for trump
i would say thank you for that um one
last question um
let's say if joel biden wins or wins the
election
and um let's say that um
he tried to impose like a mass policy
but then do you think like any of the
trump supporters or any
conservatives might actually like follow
by it i just don't see that happening
i'm sorry you said if joe biden tries to
implement what kind of policy
like like a math policy like uh like a
mandatory math policy
for for every state are you saying meth
like crystal methamphetamine i'm trying
to i'm not just not sure i'm
understanding no no no no no
math math math masked policy oh my god i
thought you said a math policy
here's the deal here's the deal uh with
that
so um ultimately it's up to governors
it's unclear whether legally the the
president can
make everybody have to wear a mask
because a lot of those decisions are
just state level decisions
but if it if it's logical to say
everybody should wear a mask for the
next two months because of what's going
on
i think joe biden will suggest it and i
think most governors
will do it um and you know what the
political fallout is i don't know i
think on that issue i think if it's the
right thing to do biden will do it
awesome yeah thank you so much if i
don't if you don't mind i'd like to give
like a quick shuttle
uh before i go i appreciate it okay um
i'd like to just like to shout out to uh
kalinski okay do
and uh the writing on the hill there was
two year three are the ones i usually
listen to every
every day so i do appreciate it very
much all right thank you very much uh
appreciate the phone call
let's go next to our caller from the 678
area code who's calling today from six
seven eight
hey david that's me at zac from atlanta
zac from atlanta what's going on
listen man it's not looking good for
biden i haven't seen a single
biden harris boat rally yeah
no you know why all of the boat all of
the biden harris boats are already
underwater the values are huge but
they're just happening underwater
so i mean what are your recommendations
providing to capture the vital voting
demographic i mean you go out there with
a speedo and some ray bans or if you had
any further
you know how can he capture that because
i don't think he's going to win the
electoral college without me
i honestly i have no idea what boaters
how do you appeal to boaters i'm just
not really sure
uh what is it that the boating community
wants what is it the boating community
needs from their leaders
i don't i couldn't tell you one of their
priorities
i mean that's the heart of america right
there so unless he unless he gets the
ball rolling here pretty quick that's
going to go to trump but it's not going
to be a good sign
i would go further i think the yacht
community
is the heart of america not the boat you
know when you say the boating community
you've got a lot of dinghies and pontoon
boats you know what i mean that sounds
like riffraff
it's the yachting community that they
need to go after
right right and i know uh there were a
couple of of the trump boats at the
trump rally in texas
that sank a few days ago but the whole
biden ship is going to sink
right hop on this pretty quick it's um
it's mariner
metaphors which we need i think
anyway thanks so much david love your
show just thought i would bring that in
real quick
all right i think that you're making a
very good point and i appreciate you
making it
let's go next to our caller from the 603
area code
603 could really go either way because i
think 603 is new hampshire
where you have you know live free or die
and you have all sorts of different
things who's calling today from 603
hello this is adam um
i haven't really been out too much but
there's been
way more fighting way more biden signs
than i thought there would be
in new hampshire you're saying yes
all right that's good yeah so
my question if i have a minute is um
i was wondering like
if we should expand our use of
government
because i think we mostly refer to
government as a
the federal government like with with
land in a flag but i would argue
if libertarians want their way and they
want to reduce the power of the federal
government
if the government
if the government is the authority with
the most power if you reduce that power
there's i would argue that there would
be
you would give the government status to
a private company because then they
would have the most power
and you would just be governed by a
different instead of
sort of a public entity a more private
entity
okay beautiful i don't know that i 100
understand what you're saying but i
think you're getting to two important
things that that are
that are crucial one is a lot of these
libertarian
uh pipe dreams or wet dreams or whatever
you want to call these things okay they
really
are just replacing government as a
regulatory body
with whichever guy gets the most guns
the fastest
and uses those guns to take control of
something and i don't know that we're
better
off with that sam cedar has some really
great calls with libertarians talking
about this
and then number two sometimes you'll
hear from these
small government libertarians that you
simply don't need
an apparatus so large as a federal
government or even a state government in
some cases
um the reality is that when you have
multi-billion dollar
transnational companies trillion dollar
companies etc
um you only the power of
of sometimes multiple federal
governments
uh across the world only that power can
actually regulate corporations that
large and adam i'm going to let you go
because it sounds so loud where you are
but i really do appreciate the question
sorry all right no problem adam from new
hampshire
seeing the new hampshire biden signs
that's good
uh i i think pointing out the folly
of some libertarian arguments that's
also very good
uh if you're holding don't hang up
because we're taking a really quick
break
and we're going right back to the phones
the david pakman show
at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show depends on your
support and the easiest way is through
membership which includes the world
famous
bonus show as well as commercial free
audio and
video streams of the show just for
members
sign up today at joinpacman.com
coupon code saves you 40 vote soon 18.
[Music]
welcome back to the david pakman show
we are taking phone calls at
617-830-4750
let's go to our caller from the 215 area
code caller from 215 what's your name
where are you calling from
hey david this is uh john from philly
john from philly what can i do for you
age
um i have a two questions for you do you
believe
that the polls are going to be open when
in november like with no issues or all
and my second question do you believe
that pilot is gonna give up
if trump wins known by popular
ball no by electro cobo by
uh doing some kind of uh
illegal maneuver
to win in binding notice of everybody
notice and do you think
buddy is going to get bored or he's
going to fight him for
okay good beautiful question so first of
all will the polls be open normally in
november the polls will be open
in different states it's going to be a
mess okay there are states where they
are reducing the number of polling
places because of coronavirus
i think we are going to see examples of
everything in november it's going to be
a mess so my recommendation is
i think the best approach is vote early
in person early in person i think is
probably
the the the best bet but we've all just
got a vote and we're going to have
a mess now is biden ready for a fight
i sure hope so you know we know that
donald trump has
lawyers ready to go to try to
stop absentee ballots from being counted
after election day
trump is ready with an army of lawyers
joe biden had better have an army of
lawyers twice as big
and john i worry that he doesn't i
joe biden should be ready to fight i
hope that he is
i don't know if he is
very interesting yeah john where are you
from original
oh he's on gabe i know i know
john where are you from originally my
friend
where are you from originally uh
dominican
dominican okay very nice and you like
philly
oh yes yeah nice i've never been but i
hear it's nice
yes yes all right my friend so how are
you voting are you planning to vote in
person
i'm planning to go in person but i am
afraid that something's going to happen
that
yeah i don't know well if it does you
let me know
if there's irregularities on election
day you let me know okay
yeah no problem all right thank you
you have a wonderful day sir you too
take care there's john from philly
originally from the dr let's go next to
our caller
from the 614 area code who's calling
today from 614
hello yes that's you
oh hi um josephine is my name
oh you're calling you're calling from
it's country code 61.
it's called where are you calling yeah
yeah i'm coming from australia
um wow victoria yeah thank you for
taking my call i
i've tried a few times and i just
thought i just wanted to comment you
know
um this is great uh now
um yeah i have so i live in victoria
melbourne you know melbourne just out of
i do do you know your geography i'm sure
of course of course yeah
um i um i suppose um
yeah i could ask a lot of questions i
could i or
talk about a lot of things but i i do
have a question for you and i don't want
to waste your time you
other call it beautiful but um
yeah i suppose do you have any questions
for me
none whatsoever no no i mean we'll no
here here's my question
this is good yeah i'll ask you the
questions let me ask you the questions
uh is the united states a laughing stock
right now in australia
oh cool yeah yeah yeah i mean look i
mean it
i i'm informed i lived in new york city
for 10 years
okay london for three years so i've and
i have close fam
uh family and friends there so i'm
keeping up to date
via shows like yours and you know stuff
i can watch
without you know you know
i i like to keep myself informed however
yeah unfortunately it is
i mean when i was you know there were
issues the healthcare system i mean the
um
yeah and uh i left just after
uh barack obama was
elected you know a really exciting time
and
um and uh yeah it is and to be quite
honest
just waiting for this whole long
exhausting and torturous reality show to
be over
right i hope the last episode is in
november because and that there's not
another season
because
some people might say okay well you're
not an american
okay nationalistic attitude thing is
we're a global society i mean 40 years
now and
i um it's been ramping up i can see
everything that's going on over the
world
mentally um it's it's
exhausting i mean i think once i saw
that um
in pennsylvania latrobe
yes uh don't yeah but i watched it
through your show because i mean
you know it was sort of a buffer but i
mean i had to i couldn't find the remote
and i had to
unplug the television streaming through
my right i'm shocked you didn't throw
the tv
out the window altogether actually sorry
yeah i know some people reported
throwing the unplugging the tv wasn't
enough they had to throw the tv out the
window altogether
yeah yeah like i mean because if you're
streaming from your devices like an
had or something it doesn't turn up
interesting ah no one had to go outside
right and then you know either side of
that you've got the posters
post postal service which and then on
on the other side of the military
honestly really
and i think to myself i'm how can you
do you want to get voted out is that you
what you want
surely not right but
like criticizing the military these two
sacred you know institutions
and john mccain oh um yes
well listen you've hit all of the
important topics and uh a number of
different things there
we uh we we hope to do
uh well by the australian people in
november and to remove donald trump i
hope it happens and i hope to hear from
you again
yeah i've got one question for you oh
you do okay
okay why hasn't there been a trump gate
sorry what why what why hasn't there
been a
trump guide why hasn't why hasn't
something been called trump
i have no idea i'm not sure i i i will
make a phone call and try to find out
trump trump trump my trump guide trump
guide
uh watergate trump gate no i understand
i understand yeah no i'm i don't know
why there's been nothing
there are too many there are too many of
them
right right okay
thank you so much for the call i do
appreciate it my pleasure no the
pleasure is all on this side of the
phone line hope to hear from you again
let's go next to our caller from the 919
area code nine
now 919 is that north carolina
maybe
no it's country code 91 i'm sorry who's
calling from country code 91
hello david it's me uh i'm from india
aniket from india love it okay yes
what's going on my friend
hello yeah so i was just gonna ask you
about um
i don't know if you talked about this
but uh you know the recent comments by
trump about calling fallen soldiers
um you know suckers and losers yeah do
you think that's going to
that the military vote will will
decrease because of that because
i saw a segment by you
i saw a segment but you were in on the
bonus show we were talking with pat
about how
the military isn't really that um uh
republican and do you think that
this will just even decrease your
support by uh voters in the military
i do think so i don't know that it's
going to be a big impact but
i think that you know we have that
military times poll from a week or two
ago
pointing out that right now members of
the military are
leaning biden by about six points i have
to believe that even if it's not a huge
impact
overall that a few more point
percentage points of military members
are going to get away from trump
because of the quadruply corroborated
story
that he called members of the military
who died
suckers and losers i think it will
affect him
in terms of his support within the
military by a little bit at least
yeah and what do you think of us is like
more
sick of frantic followers they're just
going to live in denial about this yeah
with everything else yeah yeah the
sycophantic followers will just say
it didn't happen and they'll continue
living you know living their lives and
supporting trump for sure
yeah that's uh crazy all right thank you
david for taking my call wait so hold on
a second so
what what part of india do you live in
oh i live in um south dakota southeast
india i live in
ghana and what is life like there
uh well i guess uh they're they're
copying
the us's idea of the pandemic is over
we're not going to do anything further
and
okay i guess if you want to take care of
yourself you just wear a mask
and um yeah i just had to actually have
to go out to take a picture of
the sunsets on my maps for my physics
lab
and you can just see like everything's
normal no one's
i think some people are wearing masks
but if you just came in
and you had no idea what's going on you
wouldn't you wouldn't think anything
other than
yeah i guess people are just wearing
masks more now
and it did you have you lived in an
english-speaking country or is your your
language proficiency
simply from learning english in india
oh yeah my language preference
proficiency is simply from learning
language in india
that's unbelievable going to an
university in the states
but um that is incredible but i couldn't
because i have to
okay yeah yeah i know so i am going to
university in the states but i have to
stay here because of cobin
so i hope i guess in the spring i would
be going uh
but yeah all right well listen i really
appreciate the phone call it's great to
hear from viewers all over the world
yeah i'd love to hear from you and
congratulations on 990
000 subscribers david yes 9.90 is nice 1
million i think will be a nice round
number though
let's go all right thanks so much
appreciate the phone call thank you
wow caller from india love it let's go
to our caller
from the seven one eight area code who's
calling today from
seven one eight
yeah what's up uh my name is danny from
brooklyn
danny from brooklyn what neighborhood in
brooklyn
bay ridge bay ridge that is a that is
that is one of the top neighborhoods i
would say
yeah oh well i guess so
all right well you're not thrilled about
bay ridge but what's on your mind today
uh well it's very right-leaning so you
know that's true that's uh
the major downside of it but uh my
question is so
if but when trump leaves his office that
i'm not going
not going to be silent like other past
presidents
or a courteous in that way like i
imagine he's uh
he'll be on fox news every morning and
sean hannity and o'han
so what kind of impact do you believe
this will have on society do you believe
it would be like having two presidents
where faith will listen to his command
or
that's a good question yeah yeah so
imagine so so you're saying
biden wins and trump loses whatever the
hell trump does between november 3rd and
january 20th eventually trump leaves
and biden is the actual president but
trump continues to tweet
and he continues to be right you're
saying beyond that trump continues to
tweet and be interviewed and say here's
what i would be doing here's what
should be doing will he have enough
followers where him
running almost like a parallel
presidency could have an impact
exactly yeah i honestly it's possible
and it's very scary
it's very scary the idea because i think
that you know
um 60 plus million people are going to
vote for the guy
and if he sort of never really leaves
the public eye the way george w bush did
in the immediate
aftermath of his presidency the way
barack obama did for a time after his
presidency
um it could wreak absolute and total
havoc yeah so that's interesting but you
know what
i'm okay dealing with that problem when
we get to it as long as we remove
him okay i see
yeah it's just uh you know i'm just
thinking you know
because i don't imagine him being silent
like barack obama or george w bush you
know
i'm 90 with you i think there's 10
of me that thinks maybe because trump's
this huge narcissist
it's possible trump if he loses will say
i didn't want a second term anyway and i
don't want anything to do with politics
anyway
and we never hear from him again i think
that's like a one in ten
i think the nine and ten is what exactly
what you're talking about which is he
won't shut up
gotcha all right all right dave i love
your show man
thank you thank you all right say hi to
everybody in brooklyn for me i miss miss
living in brooklyn brooklyn's great
just a just a great place let's go to
our caller from the 503 area code
um what's your name where are you
calling from 503
hi my name is louie and i'm calling from
portland oregon
uh how are you how do you guys even have
phones working there i heard that
everything was destroyed
oh i'm i'm super sorry yeah i i we we
we've been trying to keep it a secret
that that portland was just
completely leveled and raised and
there's just nothing left
um but but we got we we still got some
uh bars out here they're close to dakova
although our uh
restaurants are still uh open and such
um
which i don't mind bragging a little bit
that organ is doing
pretty well when it comes to infection
rates and things like that well that may
be but i'm sure
i'm sure you don't have any running
water anymore right
oh absolutely not all the running water
needed to be used for
uh biden's uh boater rally
of course of course so
um i do have uh so my question for you
uh concerns the 13th amendment of the
united states constitution
uh which uh section one reads neither
slavery nor involuntary servitude
except as a punishment or crime whereof
the party shall have been duly convicted
shall
exist within the united states or any
place subject to their jurisdiction
right and my question to you
is does this exception mean that
a form of slavery is still legal in the
united states
my understanding of that is that if you
are in prison
and there is a work requirement in
prison that it would be constitutional
now that my my reading may be totally
wrong but that that's my understanding
of what that means
and i i believe that you are uh yeah i
i'm with you on that
um and the reason why i say that is that
uh in oregon we've had a prison work
requirement since 1994.
right person's convicted and
as and and because of how it's enshrined
in the constitution
prisoners do not have to be paid minimum
wage right
the work does not have to be safe um and
and i'm also looking at it as both
a uh and of course you know california
which is fighting wildfires can't
pay their uh convicted firefighters
shall we say
um the two dollars a day that they've
done in the past
so um and and that's just scratching the
surface my goodness
so um but i just wanted to
uh kind of get a sort of second opinion
on it
uh yeah that's my sense of it that's my
sense of it and certainly
prison work conditions are a big topic
and something we've dealt with on the
program before and
hopefully something that when things are
more normal in this country we can
actually
deal with in a sane way yeah
absolutely absolutely um and i'll uh
i'll uh keep
my eyes peeled for anything changing on
that front uh and of course if if in
portland if we rebuild the city
no i'm saying that in chest yeah the uh
um and uh as far as uh and i am hoping
that everyone
does stay safe we've uh we have some
counties in the metro area
approaching evacuation orders for
wildfires and everything else so it's a
uh it's a real confluence or
configuration of
emergencies here it's an amalgam we
could even call it louie from portland i
appreciate the call
thank you very much david take take it
easy all right you too
uh we are going to go to a break that is
going to do it for live calls today as
always
my sincere apologies i throw myself at
your mercy
that i was unable to get to every caller
but that means we'll have some callers
next week thank you
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show depends on the
support of our viewers and listeners and
one way to keep us going is through
patreon
where you can pledge as little as one
dollar per month
or as much as you want at patreon.com
slash david pakman show great perks and
benefits as well read about him
[Music]
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
okay let's get into your questions first
one is hey david how will a vaccine
before november first
affect the election even how this is
asked needs to be clarified because
there is not going to be a vaccine
before november 1st
in the sense that anybody's really going
to be getting it the
absolute best case scenario would be
that a vaccine approval
is announced sometime in october before
the election
and presumably what that will mean is
that it is an emergency use
authorization from trump's fda whether
we trust it or not is a different
question
it is very unlikely that a full approval
for a vaccine will come in october
although it's possible
but either way the point of donald trump
doing this which i've predicted for
months that sometime during october it
will be
we got it we got the vaccine the point
of this will be
to associate himself with getting the
vaccine even if the vaccine
is from another country as we know the
uk is very far ahead on vaccines and so
are many other countries
and it is going to be a pr and optics
play now
a lot of people are pointing to this
letter that was sent out by the cdc
last week which i covered which tells
states
be ready to distribute a vaccine by the
end of october
or early november and there are many who
are interpreting that to mean
that there might be hundreds of millions
of doses
actually being distributed on that date
and that is not actually the likely
scenario
what the letter says is states should
have their plan
in place for how to distribute the
vaccine by that time
it does not actually suggest that states
will have
millions of doses to distribute by that
time
now in terms of let's
play it out trump announces a vaccine
and says we did it
we're the first to do it the fda has
determined that this vaccine is safe and
we are issuing an emergency use
authorization and will immediately start
sending vaccines around how much of an
impact would that have
first of all it would be a smaller
impact than in previous elections
why because more people than ever are
expected to vote early
and to vote absentee meaning that even
if you don't go and vote early in person
you will have mailed your absentee
ballot already
meaning that something that happens on
october 15th or 20th or 25th
may well have less of an impact this
time around than it would have in the
past
the other thing is i don't know that
that many people are going to fall for
it
um if you look at more of a qualitative
analysis like the one done by alan
lichtman for example
or or some other election predictioneers
the cake gets baked earlier than
the middle of october or november 1st or
whatever the case may be
the only counter to that and i do think
it's a relevant counter
is that if the election is expected to
be close from an electoral standpoint
even if biden wins the popular vote by a
few points as he well may
you could still have an electoral
victory for donald trump based on a few
states
if donald trump's announcement of a
vaccine emergency use authorization
on october 25th for example shifts
just one percent of the ballot of the
vote
in some states it is conceivable
mathematically that that would shift the
results
from joe biden to donald trump and so
that's why
we need to anticipate that this is going
to happen because i've been predicting
it for months
we need to anticipate that the voter
suppression that is likely to be done is
not going to figure into the polls
that the voter purges that the messing
with the post office
none of this stuff is going to be in the
polling numbers
and thus we need to do everything we can
to get out the vote
to understand that even in blue states
we need to run up the score
even in red states that biden will lose
we need to get as many votes for biden
as possible
to have the most overwhelming possible
popular vote victory in order to make it
more difficult that's all we're trying
to do we're trying to make it more
difficult
for a court if it comes down to a court
saying
you can keep counting absentee ballots
or you have to stop
that it makes the decision more
difficult for them
if the popular vote is overwhelming in
favor
of joe biden i do predict that sometime
between
october 20th and november 1st the white
house is going to send trump
to some facility maybe a pharmacy i
listen this guy's depraved i could
imagine him
going to a cvs and announcing we are
issuing an emergency use authorization
for a coronavirus vaccine there will be
no such vaccine at that cvs
it will be a photo op and i worry that
it could actually convince
one or two percent of the population in
some states and it would be very very
bad for joe biden so let's be ready
hey david are landslide elections even
possible
in the modern united states so there's a
couple different
considerations here understand that
with the electoral college system
you can have a close popular vote
relatively and a huge electoral college
victory it can happen
you can also have a popular vote win
for one candidate while they actually
lose the electoral college as we have
seen help republicans multiple times in
the last couple of decades including
most recently donald trump in 2016.
the reason in our uh country
that you are less likely to see these
overwhelming
landslide victories right now it's less
about the system the system very much
can allow an overwhelming electoral
college victory
it's more about polarization the entire
country agrees on almost nothing
i imagined when the coronavirus was
starting
this isn't how naive was i what an idiot
right
uh we're not going to politicize a virus
we're going to come together as
americans and we're going to do what
needs to be done
and we're going to keep people safe and
we're going to speak logically
and it's going to be connected to the
facts on the ground boy was i wrong
and if the country can't even agree
barely about something like a virus so
empirical so
fact-based then it is very difficult to
imagine
that you could have such lopsidedness
in the united states that you would see
such an overwhelming
landslide now that being said
how we define landslide is up to us and
you could see this november what in the
modern era
would be considered a landslide victory
for joe biden or he might lose
or he might lose now the bigger picture
is that um you have a lot of people in
this country and this gets to critical
thinking this gets to education
this gets to media literacy you have a
lot of people in this country who will
never vote for a democratic candidate
you also have a lot of people in this
country who will never vote for a
republican candidate regardless of their
platform
platforms and regardless of what they
actually stand for um
there are then a bunch of people in the
middle who will see reason
but it is tough it really requires
fixing and changing a lot of the systems
that
keep people in these filter bubbles and
echo chambers
and so when we look at how they are
distributed around the country
that's where the potential for a
landslide really comes when you look at
some of the polling for the upcoming
election and you see
wow trump is only up two in a recent
texas poll from the dallas morning news
wow trump is only winning in missouri by
five whereas he won in 2016 by 19.
demographic changes older voters dying
quite frankly and immigration from latin
america coming in
could actually create a situation where
you know
we've been saying it for a while but it
could be in four years and eight years
and 12 years
texas could be a purple state that
sometimes votes for a democrat
georgia could be a purple state that
sometimes votes for a democrat there are
others
you could actually end up with a
democratic candidate with more than 400
electoral votes
but it will likely take some time the
republican party will fight it with
gerrymandering
they will fight it with voter
suppression because they know they can't
win
on the issues the other thing to
consider is
it's not in the interests of corporate
media to have a blowout election
imagine how many people would tune out
if in june all corporate media said
this race is over and of course they
would never actually do that
but corporate media has an interest to
keep it
seeming as hard fought and close as
possible so
for the foreseeable future what do we
know we know that elections will at
least be portrayed as close
and we also know that unless demographic
changes
overwhelm the level of partisanship that
we have in this country
we are likely to see contested elections
we will put it that way
competitive elections for a very long
time
okay last question today david i see joe
biden has a nice lead
but how can he keep the lead for two
months and prevent it from slipping away
so the numbers are looking pretty good
for joe biden earlier this week we
compared joe biden's polling
to that of hillary clinton exactly four
years ago and we found that
on september 8th which was tuesday joe
biden was up 7.1 compared to hillary
clinton being up only 2.5
on that same date in 2016. so that's
good
at this point this election is going to
fundamentally come down to
turn out and foul play very few people
are going to change their minds between
the candidates
in the time that is left i don't want to
pretend that the swing voter doesn't
exist
i don't want to pretend that some people
are undecided as insane as it sounds to
be undecided right now
some people are undecided i'd love to
meet them please call into my show i
want to talk to you but they do exist
the big factors from here on out are
going to be turnout
uh and avoiding
some of the voter suppression that
clearly donald trump plans to do
so in terms of what joe biden can
actually do
number one in the debates you've got to
avoid a big mistake if you make
the debates at this point are not going
to change many minds
unless you make a big mistake and even
then what they will likely do
is keep some people home you might have
people who are leaning biden
if biden were to make a really
embarrassing mistake during the debates
i don't even know what it would be
you could have some of those voters who
say not i'm voting for trump
but i'm going to stay home joe biden
also
must encourage early voting early in
person voting and voting absentee
we also have to remember the vaccine
surprise is coming even
if it's bs we already talked about it
today the the vaccine surprise
is coming in october trump will almost
certainly announce
emergency use for a vaccine we got it
even if doses aren't available for a
long time and joe biden needs to be
ready to counter out
counteract that and then what can the
democratic party do
to make sure that every absentee ballot
is counted
that every million ballot is counted
because it is quite possible this red
mirage scenario is quite possible red
mirage meaning
trump seems to be winning on election
night small margins in a few states puts
them ahead electorally
and then as the absentee ballots are
counted which are more likely to be joe
biden votes
than trump votes because biden voters
are taking the virus more seriously
they're more likely to want to vote
by mail you see the leads start to
shrink the missouri
the wisconsin lead starts to shrink
maybe the pennsylvania elite starts to
shrink
and in advance of biden taking a lead
trump deploys the lawyers
biden and democrats need a strategy
so i don't think it's as much about
biden's lead slipping
winning by seven seven weeks out from
the election
is a huge deal for me it's more about
avoiding mistakes but fighting the voter
suppression
and the vote by mail antics and the
legal
mechanisms that donald trump will use
if the democratic party were smart i
don't know if they're smart if the
democratic party were proactive
i'm not sure that they're proactive they
would have a legal strategy
with hundreds thousands of i don't know
how many lawyers you need
plenty of lawyers ready to ensure that
no court
stops the counting of absentee ballots
that is unfortunately
what this may come down to reminder
voting starts soon
illinois early voting starts 40 days
before the election that's like two
weeks from now
maine starts 30 days before the election
that's three weeks from now
michigan you can start early voting 45
days before the election
that's two weeks away minnesota montana
nebraska new jersey a lot of these
states
you can start early voting 30 to 45 days
before the election the election is now
the election is now let's not regret
this on november 4th
we've got a great bonus show for you
today remember you can get instant
access to the bonus show by becoming a
member
instantly at joinpakman.com
thanks so much for watching today's full
episode of the show just a reminder
today's sponsor is blinkist the app that
lets you
read or listen to an entire nonfiction
book
in just 15 minutes you can try blinkist
for free
and save 25 off of a subscription
when you go to blinkist.com david pakman
i've also included the link right
underneath this video